in the lobby of Ramsey solution
Elizabeth is with us hi Elizabeth how
are you doing great Dave how are you
better than I deserve were you from
Indianapolis Indiana very cool when
you're here to do your debt-free that's
okay we've never lost a patient I know
now you're you're gonna make it I'm
gonna make sure it's okay
how much have you paid off sixty one
thousand six hundred and twenty seven
dollars and about thirteen cents
very good how long did that take 32
months Wow
and your range of income during that
time am i starting with one job was
forty one thousand six hundred and with
three jobs it was sixty six thousand two
hundred and forty-eight Wow yes what
kind of debt was the sixty-two thousand
um fifty-two thousand of it was dead and
then I cash flowed at nine thousand
about thirty one thousand was student
loans and I owed my horseback riding
instructor some money I owed eight
thousand five hundred on a car which was
the dumbest purchase ever and I had a
medical debt and just a couple little
ones and twosies so you paid every bit
of this you didn't sell anything I did
not sell anything well you have lived on
beans and rice kiddo I mean this is a
tight budget my goal was to hear you say
you killed it yeah you haven't said that
in a while well you you have killed it
you hit your goal because this is
amazing I mean you have worked like a
maniac but you've also just lived
nothing you done anything for two and a
half years now no no I I spent a little
more on fabric and then maybe I should
have I'm not much you don't have much in
this room I mean you're doing like 1500
bucks a month every month making fully
one to sixty six that's pretty stinkin
incredible the last year when I started
taxing pizzas around um I was putting
seven sixty seven percent of my income
towards debt pay off and it was about it
was about twenty four thousand or twenty
four hundred dollars yeah I was thinking
yeah that's what the numbers look
that's pretty impressive how old are you
I'm 29
okay what do you do for a living I'm a
engineering draftsmen and pizza delivery
driver formerly well I'm gonna keep
going for a few more months to get a
down payment for a house oh good for you
yeah okay well how much money of you
have been making delivering pizza
average month what are you an average I
make about a hundred slap ten dollars an
hour in tips even though I was working
23 hours a week so it's probably about
thirty thousand a year you're making
you're making a couple grand a month
minimum yeah yeah okay good for you yeah
but you're working like every night um I
worked seven days a week sometimes twice
a day and you're making anywhere from
2,000 to 2,500 a month doing that yeah
extra income mm-hmm Wow very impressive
thank you
very impressive so um what started you
on this journey and you are one fired up
individual yeah got you so living like a
Salomon you are you are rocking it um
six years ago my parents were having
some trouble paying my college and so
being a dumb kid at the time I didn't
know any better I took out student loans
and that next year they filed bankruptcy
oh yeah and I saw what a strain it was
on their marriage and I knew I never
wanted that to be me so that following
credit at Christmas my cousin Chris gave
me a the CDs the I think it's the 14
week CDs and I was like oh thanks Chris
you know a great gift yeah yeah
sarcastic thumbs up yeah I got you yeah
and then I put it on my shelf for about
a year and then I started having some of
the same issues that my kind of my
parents were having and so I frantically
I was looking for a solution and I found
your CDs and I popped him in and the
rest is history
well here we go yeah yeah no see these
are dangerous they were after you into
the vortex yeah I made that your name a
bad word for my parents ah yeah a couple
of times my brother hates it I love it
that's awesome
no I like being a bad word for people
that are missed by
very cool good for you very well done
what's your advice to a young single
lady who looks up and feels overwhelmed
but sixty-two thousand dollars in debt
how do you get out of debt what's the
key the key for me is the sinking fund
coupled with the envelope system so I
get paid weekly and so you'd say not to
make your budgets all the same for the
month well I said okay I'm not gonna do
that but I'm gonna make my weekly
budgets all the same so I divided all my
expenses into four and each month or
each week I would take 1/4 of that
payment and put it into an envelope and
so I sunk fund everything my rent and my
car payment and my $20 bag of dog food
is sunk funded and my aunt thinks that's
a little crazy but it works you don't
have to think about it and month to
month is different but week to week is
the same your aunt hadn't paid off sixty
two thousand dollars worth of debt in
thirty two months she's sitting over
there with an opinion yeah no she's
great
no but she was he was just a dog food
really you couldn't just put that in one
week yeah no we needed to we need it to
not think that's good yeah I like it and
that way it just nose to the grindstone
right and then you just bust it and
everything else goes towards the debt
yes yeah good for you so you had a
detailed plan yes that would be that
would be one item that you did to get
out of that the other item as you worked
like a maniac yes and you and you really
you really fried your lifestyle down but
nothing I mean you were scorched earth
working it's the craziest lifestyle
thing you gave up or did did okay see it
makes you just officially weird you know
those air mattresses that are sold on TV
yeah I have my parents 15 year old
hand-me-down air mattress air mattress
yeah and for the last two years it has
had a leak and a bad leak not just a
slow leak now every day when you wake up
in the morning on the floor yes
every day I pump it up when I go to bed
and every night are in every morning I'm
waking up in a crater you are too
awesome I did not want to sacrifice that
week's worth of student loan payments to
buy a mattress and now you can I can now
well I have to get
my you know yeah well reassessments but
now you could probably get your own
mattress now I mean you're doing good
may do it good thank you way to go thank
you so much our special you killed it
you really did thank you very you're a
hero I'm very very proud of you
and I imagine that folks some of them
that were doubters are now looking over
their shoulder and are proud of you too
then maybe they haven't had the ability
to drop their nose down far enough to do
it but they're proud of you too thank
you so Chris Hogan's book is on its way
to your hands in a few minutes it's
signed by him that's the next chapter in
your story I want to talk to you again
when your millionaire I will and a
millionaire theme our because you're on
your way and be outrageously generous as
you go along of course I'm actually
hosting the legacy journey February 26th
at 5:00 at Life Church Indy so if you
want to learn the next step with me then
turn into an ad for your legacy journey
plan and if you guys didn't get that all
down you can find that class is listed
among our class listings at our website
I'm sure so very well done Elizabeth
well thank you so much I'm very proud of
you all right
it's Elizabeth from Indianapolis
sixty-two thousand dollars paid off in
thirty two months making 41 oh no
making 66 probably even more than that
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream 3
[Applause]
oh man the harder you fight the more it
means to you that's what it comes down
to some of you people that wander just
kind of limp along out of debt it's not
as exciting but when you've done what
she's done you're sleeping on a mattress
every morning you wake up on the floor
because there were air runs out of it
that then you're ready to do a debt-free
scream it's a different level I'll just
tell you that's very real stuff great
job it was with great job hey she can do
it shut up I don't want any of your
whining the call of wambulance don't
tell me what you deserve
shut up you can do this stuff this is
the Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
you
[Music]